- Our next guest has
worked with big names like,
oh President Bush, President
Obama, Michelle Obama,
and someone you might have
heard of named Oprah Winfrey.
That's right.
And now she is teaming up with her mom
to serve up the first ever
homemade prepackaged chicken
and waffle mix.
It's a great new budding family business.
Please welcome, fitness
guru and bestselling author,
Donna Richardson, and her
mother, LaVerne Richardson.
(audience cheers)
Also known as,
Mama LaVerne!
- Mama LaVerne!
- Hi, Drew! We're so excited
- Oh, Mama LaVerne
and Donna!
- To be here!
- Oh, I love, love.
- I'm so happy to be
with you guys.
I'm actually just mad I'm not wearing red.
- Oh.
- This is our favorite color.
- This is about love
and legacy and we love hearts
and we love to spread love
through food for the soul.
You know, this is a time
when we really need to.
Don't you all think?
- Yeah, we need it.
- We need more love.
- And Mom cooks with a lot of love.
- Yes I do, I put a lot of love
into these chicken and waffles.
- And I'm so excited to get
in with you and Mama LaVerne
and learn about how to make
this really wonderful classic.
- Yes.
- I've eaten this
for breakfast
- And you can
- Okay. I was like,
is that crazy?
- Oh no.
Breakfast, lunch. Oh yeah.
- Dinner.
After party.
- Oh yeah.
After party, oh yeah.
- There's no bad time
for chicken and waffles.
- No bad time for chicken
and waffles, yes.
- Well, teach us how to
make this amazing specialty
that you guys are now selling.
So what's so great is now
we can all do this at home,
but we wanna learn
- You can do it at home,
yes.
- How to do it from you guys.
- Okay.
- Okay, yes,
we can get started.
And you, you know, for me,
being a health and fitness expert,
people are like, how do you, you know,
come up with chicken and waffles?
Well, this has been a
family recipe for years.
After church, we'd go to
my grandmother's house,
have soul food,
and my mom started cooking
chicken and waffles.
So I think it's for everyone.
But even when you look
at what we have here,
this is a treat.
- Yeah.
- I want people to work out
and enjoy themselves, but
this can be a treat for you.
And if you didn't wanna
have it as a treat,
we made it where you can
cook it with the air fryer.
- Yep.
- And you can bake it
and even if you don't eat chicken,
you could actually cook
your vegetables with it.
- That's right. You could do cauliflower.
- Yes, or anything, yes.
- Oh yes.
- And I'm using the corn chicken.
- Yes, excellent.
- 'Cause I haven't chicken
in 13 years, but I love chicken
and waffles 'cause I used
to eat it all the time.
- So it's very versatile.
- Okay, so teach us how to make this.
- All right. Well, I'll
start with the chicken.
So what you would do is
we're gonna have egg whites
and hot sauce that's already there.
And we probably would add a
little pinch of salt in there
and some little, a little
bit of cayenne pepper.
- I love it.
- Mix it in there,
a little bit, however much we like,
and that depends on what you like, right?
And then we mix it together.
- I can handle it hot.
- Oh, okay.
- And then,
once we've mixed it, we now
put it in Mama's seasoning.
- [LaVerne] Put it in
my special seasoning.
- Yes. And it will fry
up really good, you know?
And it just, you wanna make sure that you,
in the seasoning here,
I'm gonna pick it up.
- I like to put maybe a lot.
- You wanna make sure it's
coated, that's what I was gonna say.
- Yes.
- It's so important
that you coat it, because then
it gets that crispiness too.
And even if you're cooking
it in the air fryer,
you wanna coat it really well.
- Coat it good, yes.
- Yes.
- Can I stick it in the oil?
- Yes. Let's do that.
- Ready?
- And remember that my
chicken season can be used
for veggies
- Seafood and fish.
- Seafood.
- Ooh. Seafood!
- Other meats. Oh yes.
- Yes!
I'm just so proud of my mom
because when the pandemic,
before the pandemic hit,
she was traveling for 30
years, all over the country,
cooking for family and
friends and celebrities.
Who are some of the celebrities?
- Oh, Stevie Wonder.
- What?
- The O'Jays.
- Ow!
- Yes!
Aretha Franklin.
- Aretha Franklin,
yes.
- Oh my God,
Mama LaVerne!
- Yes.
- Do you have a favorite story?
Like something that just shocked you,
that you weren't expecting at all?
- Well, I can say one of the stories.
- Oh, please tell.
- When Stevie Wonder
was having the chicken,
he just kept having more
chicken and more chicken
and he just didn't stop.
It was like, "I want some more
of Mama LaVerne's chicken."
And you can't say no, right?
You're like, "You can have
as much as you want." Right?
- This last piece comes with
a warning, Stevie. But yeah.
- But yeah, so she's been blessing people
for over 30 years.
- 30 years, yes.
- And she did it for love and joy.
She didn't ask for anything.
And so now she couldn't go
out and cook for them anymore,
'cause the pandemic shut everything down.
- Shut us down, yes.
- And so we started mixing
the little seasoning in Ziploc bags
and mailing it out to
our family and friends
and said, "We can't be there,
but you can cook it yourself."
And then I have some spoiled
friends who live in Dallas
and they said "We want it already cooked."
So I would have a little pickup
set up outside my home door.
Like I would cook the meal, package it,
and put it outside the door
and they would come by,
pick it up, and I'd blow them kisses
and they would have
their meal and go home.
(audience applauds)
- That's so beautiful.
Now about how long should the chicken be
in the fryer, minutes wise?
- Depends on the size of the chicken.
Like if you're doing chicken tenders.
- If you're doing these
kind of tender sizes.
- They're like five minutes.
- Five minutes.
Five, seven minutes.
- Perfect, perfect.
- [LaVerne] I think you might
be ready to lift that out.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay. So.
- Got it?
Oh my God, they look perfect!
- Wonderful!
- You were so right!
- And if you wanted
to have it a little darker,
you'd just leave it in
there a little longer.
- Wanna put it?
- A little longer?
You wanna leave?
- Little longer?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I would say
just a tad longer.
Yeah.
- Got it.
(upbeat music)